all right so welcome back everyone the
next talk today is by Misha Belkin from
Ohio State
so reminder that we had the same insist
atutor Thank You Philip for the
introduction and yeah did ii think we
did Matty i did to thank you for giving
my talk well but I have some other
points too
okay so first I I wanted to call it the
power and limits of Konoe but then I
decided to call it the limits and power
of kernels so this is joint work with my
students here on mark and he he did he
did a lot of great work on this and also
with Charlie Lu and recently with my
colleague greif Vasily okay so well let
me just go very quickly sorry
well we know machine learning and AI is
very important nowadays it's kind of
pretty much everywhere more than sort of
modern electricity as I say now and it's
based on things which look like this
this is Google Earth Google Lynette and
this has about 10 million parameters and
you can see it's rather complicated so
it would be nice to sort of from a
scientific point of view to understand
some aspects of this how does it work
what works about it and what can we
understand you know there is a little
bit of sort of fog of war going on
because there is a lot of excitement but
it kind of figure out what's crucial
alright so what I would like to have if
sort of I would like to have a model for
more than image by modern email I mean
large-scale supervised learning only
that which is competitive on this
large-scale data sets at least on some
of them its analytically tractable and
convex okay pretty reasonable okay so
here is I would like further fifth
probably I will not be able to talk
about everything but basically first I
would like to talk about what are the
limits of kernels of what a kernels and
what are their limits and I I kind of
would like to argue that kernel setting
already give us a model like that that
it actually reflects a lot of properties
of neural networks at least empirically
observed and second I would like to sort
of how to make kernels competitive on
large data what are the power of kernels
yeah they serve the model for themselves
but I would like something which is
convex and tractable right I mean
certainly they work we know that but I
would like I would like something which
we can sort of understand theoretically
and ideally which would work just as
well but that may may or may not be
possible at least well on some problems
I think it's clearly possible and second
why is SGD so effective and this
actually relates to overfitting which is
kind of a very weird thing which is
going one I think and once we once we
sort of address these computational
issues of kernels
we see the modern behavioral kernels SG
is very effective for kernels they do so
overfitting and the results are very
similar to what people have observed in
neural net and acceleration actually you
can prove that acceleration is effective
despite the sort of infinite condition
number of this of this problems okay so
first I kind of repeating what not I
already said but let me just very
quickly repeat that computation is key F
erm so the empirical risk minimizer is
found algorithmically this algorithm
without the rhythms are very important
and what do we need for large data first
we have to map to fast
GPUs basically well we don't have to but
it's extremely desirable to map to GPU
what can a GPU do it can do matrix
vector product and that really limits
the kind of algorithms which are
available so we have to look at the
space of algorithms which are sort of
mostly matrix vector products not
entirely but the large degree and the
large size of the data actually leave
the number of this product that we can
take now so that kind of a summary what
the erm algorithmic require is kind of
we'd want a small number of matrix
vector product and that's about it all
right now
what is this kernel architecture so I'm
kind of thinking of this as shell or
kernel learning by shallow I mean it you
can view it as a two layer neural net if
you want you map from your original
space to some infinite dimensional
finite or infinite but I'll think about
Hilbert space infinite dimensional space
and then I do some sort of regression or
classification some linear thing in that
space using maybe a square loss or some
other loss now for kernel methods RK
chess is all well for most interesting
kernels it's infinite dimension and sort
of a typical thing would be to think
about the Gaussian kernel and then you
know so if I think most people are
familiar but if you're not it's
basically what you have you have a
classifier which is a linear combination
of those kernels supported on your data
point so you have a bunch of say if your
kernel is Gaussian which is a very
typical kernel you have a linear
combination of gaussians that's output
in and you you that for classification
of for regression now okay well there is
a long mathematical theory in
statistical theory for kernels from you
know like points in kernels machines and
so on what people observed is that they
perform well on small data not as well
on large data they perform okay and they
can be scaled but they seem to
consistently underperform and there was
some argument that maybe there is some
sort of intrinsic architectural
limitation because it's a shallow
network but it appears that a lot of
this and the performance actually
relates to the fact that if you take
standard methods and you map them onto
the GPU in an obvious way what you get
if algorithmically
rather suboptimal meaning that you with
a fixed computational budget it's very
difficult to actually fit arbitrary
functions oh function that you want to
fit and once you address this
computational reach
you get pretty major speed and accuracy
improvement okay so let me just point
out what the problem basically if you
just think about the square loss then
following this kernel machine requires
you inverting a large matrix it's
equivalent to solving a linear system of
equations K alpha star equals y so you
need to invert direct inversions and
cube now direct inversions of course is
not possible on large data like 10
million data points you need 10 to the
21 operation that's not possible
now you can do reiterative which is
gradient descent oh it's known as
Richardson iteration land Webber there
are a bunch of names for this and this
is nice
this is N squared per iteration and much
cheaper if you use gradient descent a
stochastic gradient descent it's GPU
compatible however how many iterations
do you need right that question was
asked before well let me give you an
example consider Heaviside function so
you could kind of think of a very simple
classification function you have plus 1
here minus 1 in just one dimension this
is what happens after hundred iteration
with a Gaussian kernel now let me do 1
million iteration ok that's 1 million
iteration well can you tell the
difference not very much
right almost the same thing you didn't
even get 1 in l2 loss you didn't even
get one bit of precision after 1 million
of iterations right that's pretty
disheartening I can so nothing happens
after million iterations basically so
you can imagine that to get any good
precision would require you you know to
many more than the life of the universe
probably now you can see that on real
data set time you basically there are
some subsets of some standard data sets
you can just do the fancy how many
iterations you actually need you see
that you get complexity which is at
least cubical war so it's worse than the
direct method with a small data sets or
small subsets so I can actually do the
direct method so I can pay and cube for
large data that would not be possible ok
now let me point out now the limits of
kernel and here is a theorem and I have
to say that sort of the methods we use a
really you're the proximation theory
with what those guys approximation
Theory guys development and I don't have
time to explain but it's pretty nice now
here is an he for suppose I have a
kernel operator you can think of this as
a kernel matrix so what's a kernel
matrix I have a bunch of points I have
my Gaussian rate so for every payoff
point you have a kernel K of X I XJ so
that's n by n matrix the size of that
matrix is equal to the number of points
what about eigenvalues of this matrix
well so you can prove that there are
some constants C and C prime which is
kind of uni well not universal they
depend on the kernel but they don't
depend on anything else so they don't
depend on this measure for example such
that lambda I of K is less than
something times an exponent in I it's a
little bit better than exponent but I
call it nearly exponential now this
actually gives the uniform bound for all
kernel matrices so that shows that the
small eigenvalues of these kernels must
be very small well if you actually do
this in one dimension so generate some
uniform points in one dimension just
construct the kernel run it in MATLAB
you will see that almost all eigenvalue
so say you have thousand points you will
see that 900 of them are numerically 0
it's really very close to 0 there are
these kernels are highly degenerate so
this is what I kind of call
approximation beats concentration if you
think about the Poisson being randomly
sampled you would think that there is
some bound of the 1 over square root of
n type but there is something much
tighter here is going on right you
actually have some sort of exponential
convergence to 0 which is not easily
suggested by maybe you can get something
like that further out from concentration
but it's not clear how you would get
this and also this doesn't depend on the
fact that they're randomly sampled it
just depends on the nature of the kernel
okay now theorem 2 and basically say
well let me now I actually I don't need
a square loss for this one let me just
run my gradient descent for a while
after T star
what kind of vc-dimension of functions
can air each of the tea steps of
gradient descent it turns out it's poly
logarithmic in the number of steps so
that's rather limit the fitting capacity
of my kernel for example random labels
are pretty difficult to actually fit
using this okay now well you can see
this actually in value decay they are
not quite exponential but they're this
is only like a four thousand out of
10,000 and they're like you have like
four orders of magnitude difference
between the largest and the smallest so
you if you look if you look further down
you kind of lose numerical accuracy but
you can see that like last few thousands
of them are probably actually
numerically zero as far as you can
compute them to motion okay so here is
the kind of theorem only very smooth
well there are some conditions here but
I am going to skip that only very smooth
functions can be a primal epsilon
approximated by smooth kernel and
basically you need at some sort of
exponential number of iterations of
gradient descent if your function is not
very smooth that seems to contradict to
the classical one of epsilon squared
rate it doesn't because somehow in the
infinite dimensional space and norm of
the solution is infinite you know if you
remember the boundaries like norm of W
start somewhere there and this norm is
actually infinite so in every fixed
dimension it's true but it's huge it's
gigantic and fu dimension goes to
infinity as you sample more point you
actually converging to infinity so in
infinite dimensional things get tricky
because these kernels even though
they're strictly positive definite but
they're extremely poorly conditioned so
okay let me kind of address what so this
is what's wrong with them basically that
the classification functions are not
smooth enough to be approximated by
kernels now what is happening here so I
need basically exponential number of
iteration to fit these directions and
this directions are important so for the
Heaviside case you can actually analyze
that it's pretty easy you see that you
have linear decay of coefficients for
the Heaviside function in the Fourier
base is an exponential for the kernel
that's a big mismatch
now what do I do let let me just tell
you what sort of our solution is
I mean certainly there could be out of
but this is one way to do it well
suppose my original kernel is something
like this this is a spectral theorem for
it I write it in the basis of
eigenfunctions my problem is that if I
gain values are kind of decaying too
quickly well let me just kind of flatten
them I can manually flatten them so I
construct this new kernel modified
kernel the first K eigen values of this
a equal to the kaepa very k plus ones
eigen value of that one okay so you can
kind of pictorially view this is
original kernel this is a modified
kernel now this kernel is much nicer
from there actually it corresponds to
the same or KHS reproducing kernel
Hilbert space is identical to the old
one but from the optimization point of
view this is much better because well
first you want to ek you can see it's
easy to see you just fit in one
iteration and then you have some
constant but exponentially large
acceleration for each next one so that
will converge much faster of course so
this is kind of a cartoon of this this
is all functions there's a functions
which you know gradient descent gets up
to T iteration and this is what we get
after T iteration if you could actually
construct this kernel and you can see
it's kind of like taking an
exponentially large step of gradient
descent now okay well you can say well
okay great but I didn't tell you okay
it's exponentially increased reach per
step but how expensive is each step
right maybe step cost huge potential
anymore well I thought the nice thing is
it you can actually construct something
which approximate that kernel relatively
cheaply and the way to construct it you
build a spray conditioner you basically
take those eigenvectors and you kind of
rescale this manually and then I think
using a knife from ORS video you can
think about nice remove whatever you
prefer you take a small sub sample you
compute those things approximately you
expand them and then you rescale this
kernel using that nothing about this
precondition the formed only ones and it
formed cheaply even though it's a kind
of cubic operation but it's a cubic
operation on a small sub sample of my
data
we notice there is no regularization
regularization is very bad because I
have so many small eigenvalues that I
really should put all my effort into
keeping some of them alive
like any reach for example would kill
them or kill fix which are valuable okay
now so with it basically you get this
kind of precondition graded descent if
you wish to call it a precondition
Richardson iteration whatever you like
to call the thing and basically the it's
low initial cost and you know kind of
low overhead per iteration because of
the way it's form you have maybe 15 or
20 percent in practice the nice thing is
it converges to any it converges to the
exact correct solution for any P so even
if you miss estimate P a little bit it's
okay you will just sacrifice a little
bit of your speed of convergence okay
let me skip this stochastic we will have
some result was the caste gradient
descent and in practice you always use
it with stochastic gradient descent but
I'll talk about this more let me show
you some results so these are kind of
acceleration basically you get about six
to thirty times acceleration factor
using this and if you think about like
actually overhead it's probably like
about five to thirty more realistically
but once you try them on some of the big
problems which people have tried you see
that you consistently get better result
you'll be able get better or the same
kind of results or I don't know point
seven to in point seventy point seven
percent are not really that different
but you get it with much much less
computational power so you get like four
hours of GPU versus something like one
hour and thirteen hundred CPUs so it's
much cheaper and in fact we kind of can
beat every result in the literature
there is one which actually using some
sort of learned features so it's not
exactly the same kind of way to do some
clever kernel learning but the nice
thing that you report for example result
for deep neural network well it's a
fully connected one and the result we
get is significantly better is just
plain vanilla Gaussian kernel nothing
nothing Francis yeah but with the
preconditioning of course so we get
better performance with much much less
computational budget
okay so that's that kind of how to
address it now let me tell you something
about this modern behaviour of tonal
width and let me first tell you
something about why is Gd so effective
why I think it's all effective in any
case and I think the major innovation
here if this is joint work with the way
this see you on mind Rev bacilli and I
think the major modern sort of
innovation is systemic overfitting so
it's not a new thing people have noticed
as for other boast and in fact Peter had
a slide from he nips 20 years ago which
was exactly about this type of situation
but I think now it's extremely
systematic and the number of parameters
is much larger than the training data
consistently huge so this is the graph
this is a different architecture this is
some sort of summary from this paper and
the size of the circle is the number of
parameters it varies from the one I
showed in the beginning Google Linette
is about five to ten million with like
150 million so it's hundred fifty
million parameters that you have there
all of them are like super super rich
families of functions and in fact okay
I'm not going to read this but basically
this is from Ross's Simon's tutorial
here eight months ago and he basically
says well we always shoot over feet you
can read the quote basically tor let's
turn off regularization and ography then
maybe we turn off it on a little bit n'
improve the result slightly okay
so here is here is the thing over
parameterization actually leads to
interpolation and what do I mean by
interpolation I mean that whenever you
offer parameterize you basically turn to
converge to a global minimum and a
global minimum my function value is
exactly why I so f of X is equal to Y I
there is significant recent evidence
that this kind of method find global
minima for different
of architectures in I am probably
forgetting about some work of people in
this room so I apologize for that
uh-oh what do I mean by what all local
minima have zero loss and therefore
their global minima
it's not terribly surprising they could
think about it the number of parameters
is so much larger than the number of
actions also think about local minima
right at a local minimum all my
gradients in adroid Direction have to be
zero but there are many more directions
and they're actually constrained which
are data point so it's not terribly
surprising that integer when if the
number of variables is so much larger
then there is one direction which goes
down of course it cannot go down below
zero because I conspired like my loss
function directly conspire to stop it at
zero it says it's a sum of squares or
sum of some positive function so okay so
if you kind of believe that then into a
or parameterize ation must lead over to
interpolation and there are certainly
for specific types of functions there
are theoretical results for networks so
now there are two questions why a large
model so easy to optimize and why do
large models perform well so easy to
optimize I'll I'll say something about
this in a second but why do they'll
perform well I think it's a it's a total
mystery because it does contradict
classical generalization result and not
classical most of generalization results
really and if you see actually this is
from the rethinking generalization paper
you see doesn't really matter what you
do your train accuracy is 100% so l2
loss is actually not reported here but
you can see it's very close to zero so
there is a big gap between training
accuracy and test accuracy and there is
no bound of this form which could sort
of reasonably bound that with
it's true you see yeah but it's not
interesting right sure I mean take C to
be 10 to the 100 here we go okay yeah
I'm saying there is no systematic bound
of this form which actually can give us
some sort of consistent an interesting
result in this mode there is no to say
this ball never to this results are
correct there mathematical truth but
they don't explain what we're seeing
okay let me just say one thing
think about one nearest neighbor
classifier one nearest neighbor
classifier give you zero error on your
training loss it gives twice a Bayes
error in some limit appropriately on the
test but there is no result of this form
which can kind of increase it for one
zero you need some other analysis which
you kind of use for one zero one nearest
neighbor classifier I think here's
something like that is happening but I'm
happy to talk more about that because
I'm sort of short on time and this is a
long discussion I think what we see is
that they always take hundred fifty
million parameters so the number of
parameters is always so much larger
we're effectively in this asymptotic
regime we are not taking the training
data to infinity we're taking the number
of parameters to infinity some function
of the Bayes error or some yeah okay so
I don't think margin see well so that's
that's basically my point so let me also
it's very parallel result for kernels so
it's clearly not something special to
neural net when neural networks but let
let me just say a few words about why as
GD works so well actually this is very
interesting because I think so in
general s GD is kind of so f GD you just
do one term at a time basically or some
small number of terms at the time when
you do h DD right
in general it's kind of hard to analyze
because you you can kind of increase 1
loss function but decrease the other one
so there is some sort of you have to
play with like averaging and so on
however there is a special case and in
fact it's observed I think moo lean and
buck was the first paper which observe
it there is some sort of exponential
regime for that and in fact natus paper
was also serviced explicitly it's Rachel
what happens is that when the each of
the small losses function is 0 you get
exponential convergence and that's
exactly what happens in two over
parameters regime right we have each one
of those guys is zero almost all of them
are zero I don't know and so we have
exponential converter so that's why it's
kind of like original perceptron why
does it converge quickly because somehow
the final loss is zero even in the
linearly separable case if it's not
linearly separable it will also like
okay now we can actually improve on this
result because well just expand your so
convergence is not enough because you
have to compare it with full gradient
descent and you have to look at the
computational requirements and this is a
little bit well it involves a little bit
of work kind of elementary but sort of
requires a little bit of work but it
actually turns out that gradient descent
of size 1 if a computationally optimal
so it's always best in a parallel in a
in a sequential machine you take em you
think it's always better to take M steps
of one gradient descent and take a mini
batch of size M however there is some
linear scaling here which is quite
interesting basically up to trace age so
this is for quadratic or near quadratic
watham near kind of minimum when you can
approximate it with a quadratic you have
trace h divided by lambda 1 of H and up
to that point you are basically scaling
linearly that means that if you have a
parallel
machine you are very good in this regime
you are getting something for free
beyond that you get saturation and after
that basically even if you put
infinitely many processor who computes
full gradient descent you only get a
factor maybe of two or something fixed
factor beyond that and it's very
consistent with what people actually
observed empirically in neural nets they
actually they call it a linear scaling
Rubin we can kind of increase the step
size of gradient descent more than you
would think but it's very consistent
with the regime where you actually have
this the loss is zero that each of the
small losses is zero in fact is what
they do they do some warming vacating
the code pre warming or something and
that basically kind of gets you in the
neighborhood of that and then they
crease the step size and that basically
I think what is that's what we think you
can basically look at kernels see that
what what you get internals is very
consistent with us again up to some
small constant okay let me skip this now
let me talk about overfitting
what is overfitting overfitting is this
this is when your train error is zero
right so I'm running my 35th accelerated
eigen Pro and I'm running this more and
more opposed kind of like what night it
was showing before and you basically
have zero loss you can see that l2 loss
is also very small it's like three times
ten to the minus five so it's pretty
close to zero so I'm literally
interpolating here at least in this kind
of numbers and you can see that the test
doesn't change at all one point two
three one point two zero one 2201 point
two three okay I don't know if the
difference between one point two zero
percent on one point two three percent
maybe it's unclear and so this is kind
of interpolation this you can say over
fitting in but it performs really well
now actually here is the point it's kind
of hard to observe using standard
methods not because it doesn't happen it
actually does happen it just you need
many more iterations because even after
three hundred twenty iterations you are
still kind of
not you know you're basically like here
somewhere so it's quite expensive to
observe using the standard gradient
descent but you can but I think people
have observed it less because the
computational capacity required is
nobody had the patience to run the form
enough basically especially without the
GPU you know like five years ago GPUs
were slower so it was just much harder
to observe well this is not specific to
any of this this is a large data set
timet it's basically observe exactly the
same thing so at least we try it on a
bunch of data sets it's the same so okay
why do our fitted models perform so well
we don't know however clearly this is
not something which is unique to deep
architectures and in fact kind of
boosting clearly shows that similar
things have been observed for other
things
and in fact paper pointed out that
something like that was also observed
for trees right for decision for random
forests and now but now we can actually
examine it in a convex analytical
setting so there is much more hope that
we can do this and in fact it's
interesting that laplace kernel does
seem to perform a lot like real networks
and if you look if you try to fit random
labels you actually have some very
similar behavior that oh but let me skip
that point okay so that's that's that
and okay I'm running out of time but
okay actually let me just say one word
about acceleration you cannot quite use
so it's actually much clearer what
acceleration does in the kernel case
because it's just leaning you can kind
of see that this is some optimality
properties of polynomials which you can
analyze but the condition number is
actually infinite for the things so
classical analysis done quite apply so
but you you can still prove things so we
have some results that basically that
there is unprovable acceleration in fact
chebyshev method is optimal it seems not
just for the classical case but for this
one but I'm going to just keep that
point okay so maybe I should
conclude okay first classical kernels I
think they can work as a convex method
for modern email they do show similar
performance at least with respect to
fully connected in your own networks
it's unclear for it seems that
convolutional layers are doing something
quite different and that is probably
essential so we cannot understand it
from this type of analysis we probably
need some other type of analysis
provider once computation is address
that we have competitive performance and
this kind of more than behavior whatever
that means can we design kernel for
computation now as GD is actually very
effective for a parameterised method for
what I think what happens is that people
realize that over parameterize method
somehow you can optimize them very well
and by this magic they just overfitting
it's okay
there is some sort of confluence of
locks there a little bit maybe I don't
know okay why does I generalize that's
unclear infinite condition number
everywhere I think we actually need to
think about infinite condition numbers
because once you have your data in that
those data you know once you dimension
is high enough empirically you can just
compute even if even if you have like
100 points in dimension like 50 you
probably have a lot of eigenvalues which
are very small for like a million points
in dimension a million they're going to
be solved many of them close to zero and
finally okay well so there is a
proximation clearly going on an
optimization but if so what is the
trade-off between and for example it's
not clear to me how the tist ecstatics
of data but how does it play off with
all the things and I'll stop